PhD from MIT where he won the award for
best oral dissertation material computer
science he Denton's spent some time in
Princeton and he has recently joined
Harvard he says really lovely work on a
variety of problems can sponsored just
Linden Strauss I'm streaming algorithms
linear algebraic problems via sketches
so it's very much oh and so I drink more
coffee than anyone else I know July
times faster than oh yeah
so what I'll talk about is based on a
few different joint works with Daniel
Cain and also with wigglin and I'm gonna
focus first in the talk on
dimensionality reduction for some
generic problems and high dimensional
computational geometry and then toward
the second half of the talk I'll focus
in on numerical linear algebra ok so the
first part of the talk we're going to
talk about the johnson-luna and Strauss
lemma which says that if you have
capital n vectors and you want to
preserve all the pairwise distances up
to 1 plus epsilon you can map those
vectors down to 1 or us on squared log n
dimensions independent of the original
dimensions of the vectors and it's been
used to speed up some geometric
algorithms so you know first you reduce
the dimension down and then you run
whatever algorithm you had before
it also has showed up there are many
actually bullets for the second one
we're going to see later but you know
using it and say a black box way in
numerical linear algebra and it's also
basically equivalent to a kind of matrix
needed for compressed sensing ok the
kind of matrices that you get out of
this how do you prove the joselyn the
Strauss lemma so one ways you prove some
kind of probabilistic lemma such as this
one first which says that if you have
any vector U then if you pick a random
matrix from a certain distribution it'll
preserve the norm of U with high
probability and the number of rows you
need in the matrix is depends on the
just this distortion parameter epsilon
as well as the success probability Delta
1 minus Delta and how do you prove the
metric JL based on this distributional
JL well you set Delta
one over the number of points squared
and your Union bound over all the
difference vectors okay so that gets you
the bounds that I saw on the last slide
and in fact these bounds are near tight
in metric JL and tied up to a constant
factor for a distribution on jail okay
okay so what do we do with metric jail
so how did the how did the proofs before
work for to come up with such a
distribution basically all these proofs
before took a random matrix a random
dense matrix like iid sign in trees or
iid gaussians and and showed that that
gave the distributional jael that i
talked about in the last slide the
downside is that if you use these dense
matrix matrices then doing the embedding
as dense matrix vector multiplication
and it takes you the following amount of
time i'm using the zero subscript to
denote the support size of the vector
right so M times the support size of the
vector okay and there has been work
about speeding that up okay so the first
work that looked at speeding that up you
know asymptotically was by I load inches
L using what they call the faster on
someone in Strauss transform and I'm not
going to get into the details of how it
worked but the bottom line is you can
embed a vector in n log n time okay
close to n log N and there been
subsequent works about getting that M
cubed out of the picture maybe at the
expense of slightly increasing the
target dimension but the downside of
these works is that it's slow to embed
sparse vectors kind of if you look at
the proof of why these arguments right
of these constructions even work in the
first place
they sort of say after I apply H and D
to my vector it'll be well spread with
high probability so that the P matrix
works and basically that means is you
destroy sparsity to get the correctness
of your algorithm so they're not fast
for sparse vectors okay and I claim that
we often do care about sparse vectors we
care about embedding sparse vectors
because in a lot of applications say
especially machine learning the vectors
that you want to embed are sparse so
you know treating documents as a bag of
words where the dimension is the lexicon
size and the ithe entry is say some
weighted count of the number of
occurrences of word I or look at a
matrix where you know the IJ entry say
in and say the net flix matrix you have
users and you have movies and then you
have ratings most users don't rate every
movie in your database so so you expect
you expect sparse vectors all over the
place so we want embeddings that work
well for sparse vectors okay so one way
to embed sparse vectors faster is to use
sparse matrices so I said in the
distributional Jo lemma you think a
random matrix from some distribution and
show it works so pick a distribution
that's supported on sparse vectors and
sparse matrices and what do we show in
the work with with Daniel Caine so let s
be the number of nonzero entries in the
in the embedding matrix that you get out
of the distributional JL lemma the
original works of John Saloon Strauss
and those other contemporaries is that
you get s to basically be M okay aqua
loopty showed that you can maintain the
same exact M even the constant factor
and get s to be smaller by a factor of
three so he saves a factor of three in
his embedding time and and of what we
showed down at the bottom is that you
can maintain the same m up to a constant
factor we don't get the same sharp
constant that previous work got but s is
actually better asymptotically it's
better by a factor of epsilon so it's
always better than then using the
previous matrices and we also show it
and work with win that for any M which
is less than Polly whenever epsilon
times log of the number of points you
basically need an S that's very close to
that up to this log 1 over epsilon
factor so this band is almost optimal
not just the analysis of this concept of
our construction but any map any linear
map that provides an embedding must have
large sparsity okay and I should also
mention that
if you you know distributional Jael the
dependence on Delta should be log of 1
over Delta but if you're willing to blow
that up to 1 over Delta you can even get
sparsity 1 and that's from work by
Thorpe and saying so you know what what
is our our our mapping so there's
previous work by Das Gupta Kumar and
star loesch on getting sparse JL and
basically what is their what is their
mapping look like their dimensionality
reducing map so at the top here I have
the vector U which I'm trying to embed
and I'm trying to embed it into M
dimensions so here they're they're n
buckets and is the original dimension
and here there are M buckets the target
dimension and what they're what they're
mapping looks like is for each
coordinate you just randomly hash it to
s places where s is the sparsity okay
with replacement and when you add it to
a bucket you first pre multiply by a
random sign before you add it okay
that's their mapping and what are you
know what do we give in our work well
first we just show that if you just hash
without replacement instead of log
squared whatever Delta you get log
whenever Delta and in fact that's not an
artifact of the analysis you can show
that if you hash with replacement you
really do need log squared and we also
give a different construction which is
basically if you draw it the right way
the count sketch from the streaming
literature which says that in the target
space you're going to break up your M
blocks in 2mm coordinates into s blocks
each of equal size M / S and then you're
going to hash each coordinate to one
location in each block and add it with a
random sign premultiplied and we show
that that gives the same bound as well
and in fact this is easier to implement
because you can do this with kind of
standard hash functions whereas when you
have without replacement to gets a
little more cumbersome okay and just in
matrix form so this thing here really is
what's your embedding matrix PI for each
column you pick exactly s locations and
put a random sign there and here I've
broken up the collet the rows into s
blocks each of size M / S
so how do you analyze this kind of thing
I'm not going to go through the details
of the analysis but let me give you a
little overview so in both constructions
you can write the maitre d IJ entry of
the matrix PI in the following way
Delta IJ is zero one random variable
telling you is the is the IJ entry of PI
0 or 1 Sigma is a random sign and
there's this normalization by root S and
in both constructions you can write the
difference between the projected vectors
norm squared minus the original vectors
norm squared which is 1 as the following
thing and this is a quadratic form in
Sigma you can write that as Sigma
transpose B Sigma where Sigma is this M
times n dimensional vector and now you
know you want to tail down you want to
say that the probability that this is
big is small and you can write out what
this matrix is B so there you know
there's a closed form oh sorry this
would be here I say to you here I said X
so X and u are the same thing sorry
about that meditational confusion and
the bottom line is the probability that
this thing's bigger than epsilon is the
same thing as saying the probability
that this quadratic form deviates from
its expectation and you can use the
moment method and there's a moment bound
that's known for quadratic forms it
depends on the Frobenius norm of this
matrix B and it also depends on the
operator norm of this matrix B the L 2
to 2 operator norm and once you bound
those things you plug it into the hands
to write inequality and you get exactly
what I promised you okay so I'm not
going to go through that calculation but
that's how it goes so next what I want
to do okay that's all I want to say
about generic spar scale so let's move
into some something else so I claim that
there's a natural matrix extension of
the sparse JL lemma so what's the Leung
I just claimed if you pick an N
dimensional unit vector and Pi is a
sparse sine matrix namely the
sieze I showed you before then with high
probability you'll preserve the norm of
you as long as the number of rows is at
least this and s is better by an epsilon
factor and you'll use the moment method
with the log 1 over Delta the moment or
you can take the second moment with
sparsity 1 and that's the ribs Aang ok
so let me be a little suggestive and
what's an N by 1 matrix of unit l 2-norm
I'm sorry what's a what's a unit vector
what is a unit I already said it I guess
what's a unit vector unit vector is just
an N by 1 matrix with orthonormal
columns ok ortho means nothing when you
have one column but you know it's true
and I'm trying to be suggestive here ok
so the thing I wrote on the last slide
is exactly the same as this where one is
just the one by one identity matrix okay
so this is the same exact thing as the
last slide
okay so conjecture you should be able to
have not one column but D columns ok and
that should hold as long as M is the
following thing and s is the following
thing based on the log D over Delta the
moment method so I'm gonna get back to
ya so right
so using this moment or you should be
able to use the second moment and get
that ok ok so we don't know how to prove
this conjecture right now but we can
prove something and this is joint work
with we which is you can get worse by
poly log factors in M and s or you can
set m to be slightly superlinear D to
the say 1.01 and s doesn't depend on D
at all or you can do the second moment
method and get this bound yes
yes the spectral norm yes I'll turn it
to operator and just a couple remarks so
when M is d squared public key of
epsilon s equals 1 Clarkson and Woodruff
showed this via other methods not using
the moment method on the last slide and
using the moment method using the second
moment ammonia and maenge independently
were able to get this bound as well d
square epsilon square a bit less being
one you can also get that bound using
using even another method basically if
you take the ribs and use some reduction
blackbox reduction in that work you can
also get this kind of bound yeah okay
another thing just about the moment
method how do you how do you actually
perform the moment method with matrices
well there's a classical way of doing it
that people have been doing in random
matrix Theory since at least the 50s
which is so what's the probability that
this operator arm is bigger than epsilon
you know you do the moment method this
is basically Markov's inequality after
raising both sides to the elf power and
then use the fact that well if L is an
even integer ok so what is this what is
this thing here it's the largest
eigenvalue raised to the l meanwhile
what is this thing
well this inner matrix raised to the L
it's eigenvalues are the old eigenvalues
raised to the L and the trace is the sum
and since L isn't even integer
everything here is non-negative so the
sum definitely dominates the max okay so
this is what I mean by the moment method
when you're dealing with matrices and
okay so why do we care about this matrix
extension the reason we care is the
following to say that the operator norm
of this matrix is less than epsilon is
equivalent to saying that pi preserves
the norm of every vector in the subspace
spanned by the columns of U and there
were some previous talks and this
workshop about subspace embeddings okay
and the reason we care about subspace
embeddings is you can use them to speed
up algorithms for many numerical linear
algebra problems on big matrices
if pious sports that means you can
multiply pi times a so if you have some
big matrix a or working with you can
multiply pi times a and time which is s
times the number of nonzero entries in a
so the sparser is the closer you get to
this bound here okay so let me just run
through a little bit of numerical linear
algebra what time did I start by the way
nine thirty years okay so let's say we
have a big matrix and as much bigger
than T so there are a few problems here
I'm not going to spend time on all of
them but let me just say a couple so say
Lee squares of Russian you collected end
data points each one is an RD and you're
trying to fit the best line to your data
that you can buy best I mean you
minimize the sum of squared distances to
the line okay so that's these squares
Russian low-rank approximation is
basically you know at the heart of say
principal principal component analysis
and all these things get used in various
contexts so there are some problems here
and for all these problems you can use
the SVD to get efficient solutions so
theorem every matrix a has what's called
an SPD which is writing it as the
product three matrices in this way the
middle matrix is diagonal with strictly
positive entries on the diagonal and U
and V have orthonormal columns and once
you have the SVD which you can compute
in this kind of time there's some up to
some precision and there's you know some
logarithmic dependence on precision okay
I'm not going to talk about precision
issues in this talk I claim that once
you of the SVD you can solve a lot of
problems why well let's look at least
squares regression for example you're
trying to minimize the l2 norm of ax
minus B what's the best X to choose
basically part of B lies in the subspace
spanned by the columns of a and part of
being the orthogonal complement you
can't kill the part in the orthogonal
complement right so you want to kill
everything that's in the subspace so you
want to project B down to the subspace
and that's the X that's the best X and
you can just read that off from the SVD
lore anchor
summation there's a theorem called the
Eckert young theorem which says that if
you just zero out all but the top K
singular values of this matrix Sigma
that will give you the best low-rank
approximation under say 4b Gnaeus norm
or operator norm okay great
so conclusion we can compute the SVD and
then we can solve all these problems can
we do better than that
so this is where subspace embeddings are
going to come into play so I want to
show you how can you subspace embeddings
for example for least squares regression
there are other reductions for these
squares or regression but I feel this is
the simplest to present and I'm not
going to go through all the reductions
for other problems so so by the way this
is this is known from previous work on
this problem so instead of minimizing ax
minus B for the original d squares
problem these are all l2 norms we're
gonna do it for the new problem pi X
minus PI D ok and I claim that doing
that gives you almost a good solution as
solving the actual optimal solution for
the original problem and why is that
well definitely this is true X tilde is
the minimizer for the new regression
problem right so it's better than opt
for the new regression problem then the
optimal X star and then you just write
what's this it's pi times a certain
vector that's a vector which lives in
the subspace spanned by the columns of a
and B so as long as pi is a subspace
embedding for that D plus 1 dimensional
subspace it's preserved and similarly on
the right side right hand side and you
move things around you get that so PI
just needs to be a subspace embedding
for some D plus 1 dimensional subspace
and the bottom line is now you only need
the SPD of PI a which is a lot faster
because you have a much smaller
dimension ok ok so now that I've shown
you at least one way of using subspace
embeddings let's get back to how do you
show this matrix extension of sparse
jail so remember we want to show we have
this kind of inequality the probability
this operator was being an epsilon is
that most this bound here and now
basically we just
we just need to bound this expected
trace to some power so how about the
case where Ellis - I claim that if you
take the trace to the second power you
can get a bound in sparsity 1 + M Bing D
square epsilon squared + and by the time
taking l equals 2 is equivalent to what
was in the work by my own yin may okay
so let's just introduce a little bit of
notation let the columns of this matrix
U be u1 up to u D those are the the the
D vectors in our orthonormal basis for
our subspace and recall that PI J can be
written in this way
Delta tells you whether that entry is
nonzero Sigma is a random sign some
computations which I'm not going to do
here yield the following basically the
point is you can write down a closed
form formula for what the entries of
this matrix are and now the trace of a
major of a square matrix squared I mean
we have a symmetric matrix so symmetric
square matrix right and you square it
and take the trace that's always equal
to taking for being a storm squared so
that now is just a computation right you
have you know what the entries of the
matrix are you square them and you add
them up and you compute the expectation
and you get a bound you hear that it's
at most that you plug that into the
Markov kind of inequality I showed you
and you set up em should be d squared
over epsilon squared to get this kind of
thing so that's how that goes okay so
now I want to move into how do you show
the bound where M can be very close to D
right very close to D over epsilon
squared with a little bit more sparsity
so that's gonna be a larger moment we're
gonna go to like the log D 8th moment so
I want to say a little bit about how
that proof works so first of all
whenever we have a square matrix and
raise it to the Alpha power what's its
IJ century by induction you can prove
it's this you sum over all paths going
from I to J of some product of entries
of the matrix and the trace is the
case where you're going from eye to eye
so it's it's the silver all cycles where
the last thing is equal to the first so
what's our matrix B it's s minus I so
you just write it down okay it's a big
thing but the point is you can write it
down explicitly and how do we deal with
this big thing we use a strategy that
random matrix folks have been using for
a long time which is you associate so
here you have a sum over lots of
monomials we're gonna associate each
monomial in this sum with a graph okay
it's not gonna be a bisection many
different meals can you map to the same
graph group monomials that have the same
graph structure and then what I want to
say is the contribution of a monomial to
this sum depends only on the graph
structure like the number of connected
components or the number of vertices or
the number of edges etc okay and then
I'm going to get that bound and then do
some common to torques to count how many
graphs there are yeah and this is this
is kind of one bread and butter one of
the bread and butter strategies of a
random matrix theory but of course we
have to tailor it to the matrix at hand
which is this pi u transpose pi u minus
identity oh yeah so I want to explain a
little bit how this about how this
monomial to graph Correspondence works
okay because what I'm gonna say in the
remaining 20 minutes or so is not gonna
make sense unless I talk about this
correspondence okay so for example let's
look at us taking the fourth moment okay
we're gonna have a graph here that is
going to end up having four L edges so
16 edges and how it is how does this
graph work so there are three layers in
this graph every monomial is a three
layered graph the rightmost layer
corresponds to the R is here
the R's are between 1 & M those are like
rows of pi the middle layer those are
the eyes and J's here those are like
rows of you
okay those are from 1 to n and the keys
are these case here those are the
columns of U so that's from 1 to D and
basically what the graph is trying to
capture is which ours are equal to each
other and which eyes and J's are equal
to each other because it can happen that
say i1 is equal to J 3 and the graph
will remember that because it'll use the
same vertex for both of them similarly
if r1 is equal to r2 the graph will use
the same vertex for both of them
there's going to be a little bit of
asymmetry which is that the graph is not
going to remember which k's are equal to
each other
that's k1 right here that's k2 right
here
that's k3 that's k4 and k5 is equal to
k1 so there's always going to be exactly
L left vertices so now let me just run
through how this looks so we start at k1
does that we draw the graph going from T
going from 1 to 4 1 to L we start at k1
we go to I 1 we go to R 1 we go to J 1
and then we go to K 2 now we move on to
the next case where T is 2 we start at K
2 we go to I 2 are 2 J to K 3 and then
we just keep doing that and then we
finally go back to K 1 and then that's
the whole graph that's how you got a
graph out of monomial and the edges are
labeled in the order that we take them
so this is basically this is a cycle of
the graph that starts at K 1 and ends
back at K 1 so I want to make a few
observations about what this graph
structure is useful for like you know
why am i saying that you can bound the
contribution of monomial in terms of
graph structure the firt so there are
couple things to note here every edge
from the middle to the right is a sigma
and a delta right Sigma RI and Delta RI
so this is a Sigma RI right here in a
Delta RI also so look at the edge here
from a 2
so that's like delta re that's like
Sigma r isse ia it appears twice that
edge appears twice what does that mean
it means that that particular Sigma
random variable got squared
basically the multiplicity of an edge is
the power to what you're taking a
segment okay and you have a product of
Sigma's which are taking the expectation
of if any Sigma is raised to an odd
power the expectation is zero right
these are random signs here so in order
for a monomial to contribute every Sigma
has to appear an even number of times
even powers okay so the only graphs that
matter for us are graphs where all these
edges from the middle to the right have
even multiplicity similarly how many
distinct edges are between the middle
and the right here there are for every
distinct edge is a distinct Delta term
over here so what's the expectation of a
delta term a delta is like is this entry
of my matrix of Pi zero or one its
expectation is s over m the probability
that an entry is one I mean the probably
that entry is nonzero is s over m
because there s non zeros per column
right so in this graph the expectation
of the product of the deltas is s over
is at most s over m to the fourth power
right so this graph is encoding a lot of
information about the expectations okay
so let me let me move to the next slide
basically the thing you can show is that
the expected trace of a large power is
you sum up over all graphs all graphs
that matter meaning all these edges
should have even multiplicity of s over
m to the number of distinct edges B is
the number of distinct edges between the
middle and the right later and the Z Z
is the number of vertices on the right
layer that's two here okay because you
can choose basically who those ours are
and a sum over all assignments to the
middle of dot products of rows of the
matrix you
where does that come from if you look
here notice every vertex on the left has
degree exactly two it connects two
middle people and when you sum up over
the left what you end up getting you can
show is that this product when you sum
up over the left layer here becomes dot
products of rows of u the dot product of
a with B the dot product of B with C the
dot product C with D and the dot product
of D with a in this particular graph
it's a four cycle and I'm going to call
this G hat the dot product graph that G
is encoding so highest level where are
we right now where was the overall
strategy the overall strategy was we
have a huge sum of monomials every
monomial was a graph I want to bound a
monomials contribution purely in
combinatorial terms in terms of graph
structure so this is great number of
distinct edges number of vertices on the
right that's all combinatorial
properties and then I want to do
combinatoric sand say how many graphs
are there that have all these parameters
and bound that but right here we have
something that is not really fully a
combinatorial property right if the sum
of dot products of rows of a matrix that
has orthonormal columns so I want to
bound this also in terms of graph
structure so that I can finally end up
with something that's common to tour X
so how do I do that
I claim I'm not going to justify this in
this talk that the right bound to get
for the contribution of the dot product
graph is d the dimension of your
subspace raised to a power which is the
number of connected components of the
dot product graph the doc Cottle graph
does not need to be connected it doesn't
even need to have all even edge
multiplicities as you saw on the last
slide right this does not have all the
even national capacities but it still it
still contributes to the final son and I
also claim that if you're lucky and this
graph has all even as multiplicities you
can get you can get this bound which is
d - the number of connected components
there is a proof of that I'm not going
to show
unfortunately you're not always lucky
this does not have all even edge
multiple cities right so what do you do
so you remember that your turn remember
what this is encoding this is encoding a
product of things this dot this dot
product times this dot product times
that dot product times that dot product
so let's draw a little picture this
product of four things is the same as
this product of two things times this
product of two things and let's draw an
inequality of graphs of pictures by the
am GM inequality arithmetic mean
geometric mean this product is at most
half of the average of the squares just
the am GM inequality so I've reduced
back to the case I can handle I said I
know I said that there is a proof which
I'm not going to show you that handles
the case when jihad has all even as
multiple cities so I've reduced to that
case but there's a problem here the
problem is that I increase the number of
connected components imagine that I have
an L cycle and not a four cycle
I moved from one connected component
namely an L cycle to having no matter
how you partition edges in an L cycle if
you do this a MGM trick one of you're
one of these things is going to have at
least L over two connected components
and then you're just totally hosed okay
so how do we get around that the way we
get around that
is the following which I think really is
kind of the contribution of our of what
we do because and the moment method
itself is an old thing right so so
really the thing that required us to be
a little creative was that we use the
following theorem in a way that I'm
going to show you very soon there's this
thing called the Nash Williams theorem
which says that if you have a graph with
edge connectivity at least two K it has
K edge disjoint spanning trees meaning
what is edge conductivity 2k every cut
in the graph has at least two K edges
crossing it okay I claim that if every
connected component of the dot product
graph has two edges storing spanning
trees we're done
why are we done because over here I
could have partitioned this this graph
in any way I wanted I could have
partitioned the two edges any way I
wanted if it has towards joint spanning
trees I'm going to place one spanning
tree on one side one spanning tree on
the other side I haven't destroyed the
connectivity at all am GM and now this
trick actually worked without changing
the connectivity at all
unfortunately the four cycle doesn't
have to registration spanning trees and
unfortunately many graphs menu dot prod
aggress that you get don't have to add
restraint spanning trees so what do you
do well if some connected component is
not for edge connected well if you sorry
if it doesn't have tour destroyed
spanning trees then by the tech Nash
Williams theorem that connected
component could not have been for edge
connected that's what the theorem says
what does that mean it means that
there's a cut with less than four edges
crossing it well you can prove that this
every every connected component is rail
arian meaning the number of edges
crossing a cut is even and we're
focusing on the connected component here
so it's connected so the number one is
crossing a cut is not zero it's not zero
and it's less than four so it has to be
two right and I can use that fact to
make progress in the following way so
here is a connected component which is
messing us up it doesn't have to are
destroyed spanning trees so by by the -
Williams theorem it has a cut of size
two let's write down what that means in
terms of this sum of products of dot
products of rows of the matrix u we have
all the dot products specified specified
by edges on the T side of the cut those
are these dot products we also have the
edges on the T bar side of the cut those
are these dot products and then we have
two edges crossing the cut that's the
dot product between this between the CI
throw into a throw and the B throw in
the D throw and I've suggested Lee under
braced something on this slide namely
all of this stuff which is the stuff on
the T bar side of the cut and what is
the type of what I've under braced it's
a matrix
so really this dot product graph encodes
the same exact information as this one
when you eliminate the T bar side of the
cut and replace it with a matrix so
here's the strategy
repeatedly eliminate size two cuts until
every connected component has to our
disjoint spanning trees you're going to
accumulate matrices on edges along the
way you prove the lemma that shows that
all of these matrices you accumulate
have bounded operator norm and then you
show that you can still handle even edge
multiplicities even when you have these
M's that have bounded operator norm so
you can apply the a MGM trick on the
final thing after all these iterations
and get the bound and then now
everything is in terms of combinatorial
quantities number of connected
components number vertices and other
missing edges then we do combinatory ok
ok so conclusion I think I have what how
much time five minutes ok so some of the
recent progress one thing we can show is
that whenever you have a subspace
embedding that doesn't even need to look
at the subspace but randomly works with
good probability we can show that you
need D over epsilon squared rows okay
every subspace has a subspace embedding
with D rows with exactly D rows but if
you have to be oblivious to the input
you can show that you need D over
epsilon squared roofs another thing is
we can show some trade off which is not
optimal I'll get to that on the next
slide between the sparsity and the
number of rows you need in such an
oblivious subspace embedding okay
the last thing I'm gonna I'm gonna put
on the slide so let's be slightly more
oh oh yeah it's coming on the next when
I click sorry yeah okay so I want to be
a little more metal so the Jo lemma as
it stated says you have this set of
vectors and you want to preserve it and
what we showed is what the sparsity
needs to be and what the dimension needs
to be then there's subspace embeddings
it's really the same problem except the
set of vectors i want to preserve is not
an arbitrary set of vectors it's a d
dimensional subspace
then compress sensing people care about
our IP what's that is the same kind of
thing except the set of vectors you want
to preserve is again it's not arbitrary
it's the set of all case force vectors
in RN so then you could be a little bit
meta and say you know let me prove a
master theorem such that if someone
gives me a set of vectors T and says
what's the number of rows I need to
preserve T and what's the sparsity I
need to preserve T I can just give them
an answer in terms of the geometry of T
so that's something that we were
interested in and we are able to provide
bounds on the number of rows and the
sparsity to preserve an arbitrary
bounded set in terms of the geometry so
case farce vectors is one example some
space is another example arbitrary set
is another example and you can come up
with lots of examples that you would
care about and if you don't care about
sparsity at all there's been a bit of
work on that to show what M needs to be
but then s would equal M those are
against random matrices and what we're
able to show in this work is basically
the sparse analogue if you care about
sparse random matrices what do the
number of rows need to be and what is
the sparsity needs to be in terms of
some geometric quantities that depend on
the geometry of T right so if you give
me a T I can tell you what you need and
that's the star sorry about that yeah I
need to get better at Beamer so that
that shows one needs to show okay good
so other open problems I'll list them
here and I guess I'm sorry oh yeah I
don't know so so the third one though
the third one really bothers me because
we're losing these log factors in the
moment method but let's say you don't
care about sparsity at all you just want
to show that d or epsilon squared rows
works to get a subspace embedding
there's a net argument that will do it
for you not not the moment method that I
showed you before and then the net
argument gives you the right answer it
gives you D epsilon squared but prove to
me that same exact bound not using a net
argument prove it using the moment
method I don't know I don't know how to
do that even with a dense random matrix
then that really bothers me if you take
a dense sine matrix I mean
you take a dense Gaussian matrix you can
exploit some Gaussian properties but
basically you know we're still losing
log factors that we really don't need to
lose in the moment method and that
bothers me
also the trade-off that I showed with
Hui em was deep to the 1 plus gamma and
s had to be at least this but we didn't
have this epsilon squared here in our
trade-off and that's something that is
wrong is wrong in the trade-off we prove
and there's also this last problem so in
the last I guess minute or two or
whatever is left this questions thank
you
yeah yeah yeah sure so it's probably
easiest to explain and say the previous
works when you didn't care about
sparsity at all so what was the thing
that parked that probably came up there
so there's this thing called the
Gaussian mean width of a set of vectors
so first of all take T so it's
normalized so all the vectors in T have
unit norm Euclidean norm and the
Gaussian mean width is you take a random
Gaussian vector with say identity
covariance matrix and you look at the
soup overall X and T of G X that's the
gosh I mean with and it turns out that
the number of rows you need is the
square of that the jaw should mean with
for a set of n vectors is never more
than log n so it recovers the JL Emma
for example but if your if your vectors
are well clustered so kind of discussion
mean with captures the cluster ability
of your vectors in some very precise way
and if they're well clustered you can
get away with fewer dimensions yeah yeah
yeah so yeah so except what we get right
now is kind of rough and there are lots
of log factors that we should need to be
able to need to shave but yeah we can
get something also for a sparse because
a sparse analogue when PI's